[Music]
full-time female workers in the United
States earn about 79 cents for every
dollar that men make boo hiss today is
equal pay day when a woman's pay from
January last year to April 4th this year
finally equals a man's earnings for 2016
hundreds of small businesses and cities
across the country will offer discounts
of about 20% today and that represents a
percentage by which paychecks for women
are smaller than a man one of those
companies is Tamara Mellon the business
is named for its creator a co-founder
and former chief creative officer of
fashion house Jimmy Choo she recently
relaunched her brand after filing from
bankruptcy in 2015
tomorrow good morning good morning so
tell us about relaunching so relaunching
has been very exciting I did by now
where now 3 years ago and sort of ahead
of the pack and what I realized is you
can't be one person standing out there
alone you need a critical mass to affect
change so I put that company through a
bankruptcy pulled all my business out of
wholesale channel out of department
stores and we launched it as a director
consumer business and that is really the
next generation of luxury brands and how
they're going to be built and now we're
on fire modifier well I like this icky
song when it didn't work out though the
first time you said there was a lot of
shorten Freud for you where people are
saying yeah yeah yeah she failed but
that only motivated you did it not it
totally motivated me because I
absolutely believed in my vision and I
just knew it was the execution of it I
didn't execute it right the first time
around the idea was right but the
execution was wrong and you can't be put
off by your failures you have to kind of
dust yourself off and do it again and
you said women shop differently now you
said there are no women under the age of
50 in the department store that is that
is true so what's happening we the
fashion industry is being disrupted like
the film industry went through several
years ago we first saw it with music
music industry went through it with
music then we saw the film industry
we've seen a disruption in transport
with uber and now it's the fashion
business now does that mean all the
big-name shoe manufacturers are going to
have to shift online
or not survive yes it does so basically
the way most luxury brands look at their
business it's about 10% their business
but that's not how the next generation
of luxury brands are going to be built
it should be 90 percent of your business
should be online because nobody goes
into department stores anymore we know
that nobody under 50 goes in everybody's
shopping online because it's a better
experience you're better service you
have it delivered to your home you buy
great quality products and then what
I've done by going direct to consumer
we've been able to reduce our retail
price and sale the same quality shoes as
I did when I was at Jimmy Choo well
there's still a little pricey you will
admit that right there's still it cost
me a lot to make them yeah I made in
Italy oh they're very cute and they are
you know a lot of money in that Li's I
mean but they're still a little pricey
and you say they never go on sale except
for today except for today Tamara Mellon
shoe yeah let's talk about pay equity
okay no you are so make make what
brought you to this issue and what you
hope to see so what brought me here was
very personal when I found a Jimmy Choo
as 27 years old and I wanted to make
beautiful shoes I had no idea the
challenges I was gonna face being a
woman in business and I did a few
private equity deals with my business
and what I realized going through those
deals I was being paid less than the men
who worked for me and that is why I've
become quite an even though you were the
boss I was the boss I was the founder of
the company I was a major shareholder
but I but I had a boardroom that was all
men I was the only woman on the board at
Jimmy Choo and then when I looked
through the due diligence I realized
that the men who work for me were paid
more than me and that was and that is
why I'm very passionate about equal pay
for women yes yes and the Ranger your
shoes is what - what just so people know
so wait so we go from 350 up were up to
under a thousand all right I'm
1600 for them legging boots so if you
want the boots hand they are going don't
you very much to Marilyn